this video is brought to you by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash biographic so
use the code biographics to grab a
two-year plan for just 99
more on them in a bit
he wasn't a mob boss he wasn't a cappo
or an underboss or any other
high-ranking member of the mafia he
didn't even have a gangster's name he
was just a mid-level wise guy so
how come henry hill became one of the
most famous mobsters of all time the
answer
to this is goodfellas barton scorsese's
iconic masterpiece hailed as one of the
greatest crime movies of all time which
tells the story
of henry hill from his beginnings as a
young thug to becoming
a wise guy working for the luchazi crime
family to testifying against his former
associates and entering the witness
protection program the movie made
henry hill famous but there was another
important aspect that made this
situation unique
goodfellas was based on the book wiseguy
life in a mafia family a true crime
account by
nicholas pelegi which chronicled hill's
exploits in the mafia and presented a
detailed and ruthless account of
the life of a mobster told from a
first-hand perspective with the help of
henry hill himself
unsurprisingly the book will serve as
our main source today as we bring you
the story of the man who always wanted
to be a gangster
in order to become a somebody in a
neighborhood full
of nobodies
[Music]
henry hill was born on june 11th 1943 in
brooklyn new york one of eight children
to
henry hill senior and camala costa
although his mother was sicilian his
father had irish heritage and right off
the bat this limited hills options in
his criminal career in order to rise
through the ranks of the mafia and
become a maid man he needed to be a
full-blooded italian no exceptions were
made
this meant that henry hill could only
ever be an associate no matter how
valuable or effective he proved himself
to be
his fascination with the mob came from a
young age there was a cab stand right
across the street from his home which
served as a local gangster hangout
young henry would spend ages looking out
of his window with oar at all the men
who went there
who were unlike everybody else in the
neighborhood they arrived at the cab
stand
driving long black lincolns and
cadillacs they wore platinum watches and
diamond rings and
had on big expensive coats henry didn't
exactly know who they were
he just knew that he wanted to be like
them in 1955 when he was 12 years old
henry took the first step towards his
new career path and walked into the cab
stand
looking for a part-time job there he
would meet the man who would go on to
have a tremendous influence on the rest
of his life his name was paul vario and
he owned that cab stand along with a few
other businesses in the neighborhood he
was a kappa regime with the luchezi
crime family one of the five families of
new york and had his own crew which
included his brothers
in the movie goodfellas he was
identified as paul cicero and was played
by
paul savino varya liked the kid so he
made him his gopher who would go on
small errands such as buying cigarettes
or delivering messages
a while later the two of them began
making the daily rounds together driving
around in
various black impala with him waiting in
the car while
henry went out and brought people to him
for conversations or collections by the
time he turned 13
henry was already making more money than
he knew how to spend he had bought his
first fancy suit and combed back
his dark slick house so that from a
distance he looked like a mini version
of the gangsters that he had marred
school didn't present and interest him
anymore he often skipped class so that
he could work
vario or sneak into the racetrack or
just hang out at the cab stand when he
turned 14 henry was presented with a
union card
and put on the payroll as a bricklayer
even though he didn't actually have to
do anything most of his weekly salary
went to the various of course but that
was the push that finally made
him drop out of school altogether around
that same time another important figure
walked into henry's life
his name was james burke aka jimmy the
gent and he was an associate of the
barrios who
often showed up to the card games in
hill's own words jimmy was already a
legend even though he was only 25 years
old at the time the first time they met
henry was blown away by the way jimmy
was spreading his cash around
he said that all the other gangsters
were pretty cheap they would tip a
dollar every now and then but they
always resented it jimmy burke on the
other hand was spending hundreds of
dollars on tips without a care in the
world
henry saw the doorman get 100 bill just
for opening the door for jimmy
the barman also got 100 for keeping the
ice cubes cold
meanwhile henry got a 5 tip every single
time he brought jimmy another beer or a
sandwich
once jimmy started taking a shine to the
kid those five dollar bills turned into
twenties
according to hill jimmy burke was one of
the most successful hijackers in the
city specializing in cargo trucks going
to and from the airport he targeted
hundreds of trucks a year and earned his
nickname of jimmy the gent from his
habit of putting a 50
bill in the wallet of the driver that he
was robbing at the same time
hill considered burke to be a very
dangerous and paranoid man who would not
hesitate to kill somebody who angered
him he was the type of scary guy that
other scary guys were afraid of but his
violence and unpredictability were
tolerated because he was one of paul
vario's biggest earners just like henry
hill
burke had irish heritage which meant
that he too could never become
anything higher than an associate even
though he made a lot of money for the
luchezi crime family he also was one of
the main characters and goodfellas where
he was named jimmy conway and was played
by robert de niro now we'll get into
hill's life of crime in just a sec but
first quick word from today's video
sponsor nordvpn so you might have
noticed that
now run about 89 youtube channels on the
words i'm online a lot and i talk with
people every week who are
using the internet with no protection no
vpn like is the 1990s or something but
vpns aren't just a more modern way to
use the internet
they just make it straight up better and
with nordvpn you can rest easy knowing
that your internet uses safely behind
the wall of next generation encryption
block malware and bypass annoying ads
that are tracking your web traffic it's
just a
much more secure online experience if
you're worried about data logs
don't be nordvpn doesn't keep logs on
your internet use because
they know that what you do online is
none of their business what they do do
is give you more than 5000 server
options scattered across 59 countries so
your ip can live wherever you want it to
and that access can provide you with
loads of new options from shopping to
streaming
just one click and you're good to go so
regardless of whether you're considering
a vpn for yourself or as a gift for
another internet user
in your life nordvpn gives you options
there's never been a better time to
enhance your online experience with
nords head to nordvpn.com forward slash
biographics or use the code biographics
at checkout there's also a link in the
description below and
let's get back to the video
[Music]
hill committed his first serious crime
when he was around 15 years old
somebody had opened a rival cab stand
around the corner from the one owned by
barrio and tried to undercut him by
lowering prices and offering discounts
for special affairs
fixing this problem was left up to henry
tuddy barrio paul's brother
and a drum of gasoline one night after
everyone at the rival cab stand had left
the two of them went from taxi to taxi
henry broke the windows with a hammer
and tuddy shoved gasoline soaked
newspapers inside
afterwards study backed off to a safe
distance and hill ran from one cab to
another throwing matches inside each one
of them
the following year hill was arrested for
the first time alongside another one of
the barrios paul's son
lenny when the two tried to use a stolen
credit card henry got roughed up during
the interrogation but he did exactly as
he was supposed to do
and refused to sign or say anything he
kept quiet during his arraignment as
well and the lawyer on various payroll
got him off on bail
afterwards there was a big party in
henry's honor first at a bar and then at
a cab stand to celebrate his first
arrest it seemed like henry's rise
within the barrios organization was
guaranteed but in 1960 the 17 year old
did something unexpected which
left everyone a bit perplexed he
enlisted in the army where he would
spend the next three years of his life
why exactly he did this remains a bit
uncertain although he claimed it was due
to all the extra attention that the
mafia was receiving from law enforcement
at the time some even speculated it may
have been an attempt to
go straight but if anything henry put
the skills he had learned from his time
at the cab stand to good use
when he started working in the kitchen
he saw that a lot of food was being
thrown out because
the army always ordered more than
necessary he quickly established a
network of restaurants and hotels in the
area surrounding fort bragg where he was
stationed and began selling the extra
food to them with the money he made hill
set up a loan sharking business for the
other soldiers and then started hosting
guard and dice games histones in the
army ended in the stockades
serving two months after getting into a
drunken brawl with some marines and then
stealing a sheriff's car in 1963 henry
hill returned to new york and resumed
his career as an up-and-coming mobster
working for paul vario
at first he was often paired up with
lenny barrio because they were around
the same age however paul soon moved
lenny to working as a bartender in a
fancy restaurant known as the azores
which was
owned and often frequented by tommy
luchezi head of the entire family that
was when henry started working more
often with jimmy burke but as fans of
goodfellas know there was a third man in
the team
in the movie he was tommy devito played
by joe pesci in real life
he was tommy desimone the youngest and
craziest one of the group his
grandfather and his uncle both served as
the heads of the los angeles crime
family at different times while his
older brothers worked for the gambino
family in new york
so desimone had always been around this
life it seemed inevitable that
he too would eventually join a crew and
he started working for
porvaria when he was 15 years old he'll
remember the day he first met tommy who
was seven years younger than him jimmy
the gent brought him around the cap
stand hill described him as a skinny kid
wearing a wise guy suit and a pencil
moustache because jimmy was a friend of
the desimone family he wanted henry to
take tommy under his wing and make him
part of the cigarette selling operation
that he was handling at the time the two
quickly became friends and partners in a
whole bunch of other rackets such as
stealing cars lending money committing
fraud and defencing stolen goods
from 1966 they also started doing
hijackings with jimmy burke
they were still just street level wise
guys though and they needed a big
caper if they were to move up in the
world in 1967 this came in the form
of a major airport robbery just to
clarify this is not the lufthansa heist
depicted in the movie which came about a
decade later oh
this was a smaller much more
straightforward job that basically saw
henry and tommy walk in with an empty
suitcase
fill it with money and walk out without
anyone ever realizing it
once they started working with burke the
two of them began meeting people who
were part of jimmy's network of
informants who
tipped him off about good scores one of
them was bobby mcmahon nicknamed
frenchie because
he had worked for air france for a long
time he told hill over contract that the
airline had to bring in us dollars from
businesses in asia and deposit them
in american banks he also told them that
the security was pretty lacks at the
cargo terminal at jfk international
where the money was kept until it was
ready for a bank pickup
the biggest obstacles that the crew had
to overcome were a locked door and a
stubborn security guard who wouldn't
take a bribe
they solved these problems by having
frenchie distract the guard one night by
taking him to a steam room to meet some
girls which
gave them time to steal his key make a
copy and return the original without the
guard noticing the night of the heist
henry and tommy walked into the cargo
terminal when the guard was on his meal
break
he was carrying the biggest empty
suitcase that he could find and entered
the storeroom without a problem they
knew what the money bags
looked like white canvas bags with red
seals they crammed seven of them inside
henry's suitcase and simply left the
airport without care in the world
walking away
with 420 thousand dollars the theft
wasn't discovered until the following
monday
in his later years henry hill always
proclaimed that he had been a money man
for the mob and stressed time and time
again that he never killed anybody with
that in mind he also admitted that he
saw plenty of people get murdered
and that he helped dispose of their
bodies this was not the case with tommy
desimone who
henry described as a total psychopath
hill admitted that he didn't know
exactly how many murders de simone had
committed
him and another mobster named stanley
diamond killed a union guy in his own
home
they were just supposed to rough him up
but tommy beat him to death out of anger
having to drive all the way to new
jersey and back
on jimmy's orders tommy strangled one of
burke's old partners called
remo with a piano wire out of fear that
he was talking to the police then
there's the notorious scene in
goodfellas where tommy shoots and kills
a kid named spider during a card game
that one
was also real but the one that ended up
stealing tommy's own fate was the murder
of billy bats
real name william benveiner billy batts
was a mobster with the gambino crime
family in 1970 he had gotten out prison
after a six-year stint and was
celebrating his release at a club owned
by jimmy burke
named robert's lounge tommy desimone was
20 years old at the time and he had been
just a kid the last time billy batt saw
him therefore when tommy arrived at the
club bats made some
jokes at his expense asking if he still
shines shoes
this made tommy very angry but there was
nothing he could do about it billy bats
was
a made man he was a full member of the
mafia which pretty much made him
untouchable as far as other mobsters
were concerned
unless they received special permission
from the boss the punishment for
attacking let alone killing a maid man
would have been death
however tommy desimone was not the most
level-headed guy in the world
he kept his temper at the time but
privately he told henry and jimmy that
he intended to kill
billy batts that is exactly what
happened although it wasn't spur of the
moment
like in the movie instead it took place
a few weeks later when billy batz was in
one of hill's joints jimmy burke was
with him swapping stories keeping him
happy and drunk
it got late and almost everybody went
home that was when tommy walked up to
bats and
started pummeling him in the head with
the butt of his gun while jimmy held him
down
there was an associate of theirs in the
club called alex corcione henry grabbed
him and
quickly threw him out of the bar to keep
him safe and by the time he had returned
billy batz was dead and
tommy was placing him inside a body bag
at least that's what they thought
while they were driving to get rid of
the body they started hearing noises
coming from the trunk they pulled over
opened the trunk tommy smashed him with
a shovel
making sure that this time billy batt
stayed dead
the murder of bully bats would have
consequences but not until nearly a
decade later
the first half of the 1970s were a quiet
period for henry hill mainly because he
spent time in prison in 1972 he was
sentenced to 10 years inside
louisburg penitentiary for extortion he
only served six but it was during this
time that hill started dealing drugs
since he had the connections to get them
smuggled inside the prison once he was
out he'll continue trafficking since it
was such a lucrative business
technically he wasn't supposed to do it
since the luchaz family had banned the
drug trade but if anything hill ramped
up his operation he developed a network
of mules he began
handling wholesale quantities and he
also brought birkin on the business
soon enough he was making a lot more
money than he had ever made in his
criminal career but his pals were
planning something even more audacious
known as the lufthansa heist it was at
the time the largest cash robbery in
united states history
on december the 11th 1978 criminals made
off with five million dollars in cash
plus another million in jewelry
stolen from the lufthansa cargo terminal
jfk international airport
almost none of it was ever recovered and
despite a massive fbi investigation the
only person ever convicted was a
small-time player named louis verner
who served as the inside man unlike the
air france heist
henry hill had almost no involvement in
this one other than receiving the tip
and passing it along to jimmy the gent
although it was never charged for it
burke was the one identified as the
mastermind of the whole thing
ultimately it may have been a good thing
for hill that he stayed out of this
heist because soon after it happened
a lot of people supposedly involved in
it started dropping dead
it began with parnell stax edwards who
drove a black
forward van which served as the getaway
car he was supposed to have it destroyed
at a junkyard but instead he drove it to
his girlfriend's apartment where he
parked it in front of a fire hydrant
the police found it two days later and
recovered multiple sets of fingerprints
from inside the ban just a week after
the heist edwards was
shot and killed in his apartment the
following months came the death of
martin krugman the guy who
originally had the tip about the heist
by the summer of 1979 eight people
associated with the robbery were either
dead or missing
most people hill included regarded this
as jimmy burke cleaning house after
edward's screw-up since
he knew the police were on their trail
however hill also speculated that jimmy
may have intended to do this from the
very beginning
in order to increase his share of
profits another person who disappeared
around this time was tommy desimone
although he probably took part in the
lufthansa heist nobody thought this was
the work of jimmy burke
instead it was believed that this was
revenge for the murder of billy batz 9
years earlier although who exactly was
responsible remains a mystery to this
day
hill always maintains that it was john
gotti himself the future head of the
gambino crime family who killed tommy
although he did change some of the story
details over the years
other culprits have been put forward but
there is no definitive answer as to
simone's body has never been found
[Music]
hill couldn't help but notice that all
the people around him were dropping like
flies
he was realistic he understood that
under the right circumstances all of his
past history with guys like burke or
paul vario
would mean little they would bump him
off in a heartbeat in order to protect
themselves
those circumstances occurred in 1980
when hill was arrested for drug
trafficking
by this point he was an alcoholic and a
coke addict but was still clear-headed
enough to realize that his arrest
gave his mobs to buddies a strong reason
to want him dead in fact the fbi even
played him a tape where two of his
associates named anthony stabile and
angelo cepe were talking about getting
rid of hill because he was a no good
junkie but it wasn't until the feds got
burke on tape talking with paul vario
about killing hill that he finally
understood that his days were numbered
he only had one choice testify against
his former colleagues
and receive witness protection hill's
testimony helped secure 50 convictions
both jimmy burke and porvario were
imprisoned on various counts and died
there
after the trials were over henry hill
took his wife karen and the two children
and entered the witness protection
program they moved around the country
from city to city sometimes leaving
their old life behind with
just a few hours notice this was the
point where the movie ended but in real
life henry hill never proved able to
walk the straight and narrow in the
early 90s he was kicked out of the
program after several new arrests on
drug charges around that same time his
wife divorced him and
after over a decade of using multiple
aliases henry hill started using his own
name again he felt that everyone from
his past life who
may have wanted to hurt him was either
dead or in prison not to mention that by
this point goodfellas had been released
and hill was keen to enjoy his newfound
fame he gave interviews
wrote new books appeared on the howard
stern show he even told his own line of
spaghetti sauce
he also kept getting in trouble with the
law with the last arrest occurring in
2009. hill died three years later
age 69 following a heart attack securing
for himself a permanent
and unique place in the annals of crime
so i really hope you found that video
interesting who did please do hit that
thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
you